VETERANS AND MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS WILL BEGIN AT SIXTY
SECONDS.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE CALL
WITH NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERINGS GUIDELINES. THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS IT TO NORMAL
PRACTICE IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC. CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLD THEM FREE TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. HE WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO AND THE
ACCESS CODE NUMBERS. EIGHT NINE
THREE SEVEN THREE FOUR THREE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO TELECONFERENCES TEAM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND
OR OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
THE OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE SHORT
WAIT ONCE WE RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE IT. AND YOU'LL
HAVE AND YOU WILL NOW BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING. SERVICE ADD OR THE
CONNECTION WILL BE MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR MEETINGS AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
THANK YOU. FOR NOW LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BEFORE WE
CONTINUE TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM I'D LIKE
TO REMIND THE MEMBERS TO TURN
ON THEIR MICROPHONES.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARCHULETA THE LETTER HERE GROW
HERE GROW HERE EGGMAN YOUR
EGGMAN HERE MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
HERE NEWMAN. NEWMAN HERE ROCK
HERE ROCK HERE NUMBER. NUMBER
HERE. FORMS ARE. BECAUSE OF THE
NOTES WE HAVE A QUORUM AND A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED- WE
HAVE THREE BILLS TODAY- ONE IS
ON CONSENT SO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
JOSH BELL CENTRE JOSH NEWMAN.
HAS MADE THAT- MOTIONS AND ONCE
AGAIN CENTERS PLEASE TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE SO EVERYONE CAN
HEAR YOUR VOTE- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARCHULETA. I
ISOLA HI ROSE. GROVE I GROW HI
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN HI MELENDEZ
FIVE MELENDEZ HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN
HI ROTH ALL RIGHT ROTH HI
NUMBER. NUMBER HI. THE
CONSULTANT NOTES THAT IS I
SEVEN ZERO NO. THE DALLAS
MORNING WHAT THE FIRST A BILL
TO BE PRESENTED WILL BE SENATE
BILL FORTY THREE CENTER- BURKE.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR. AND YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING FROM YOUR
DESK WILL WE WILL NOW- ALLOW
YOU TO PROCEED WITH PRESENTS
PRESENTATION OF SENATE BILL
FORTY THREE GO AHEAD SENATOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR WORKING ON THE BILL TO
IMPROVE THE BILL- AS SOME OF
YOU KNOW. THE THERE'S BEEN AN
EFFORT TO BUILD A CEMETERY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND EVEN MORE PARTICULARLY AT
THE LOCATION F THE FORMER EL
TORO MARINE CORPS AIR STATION-
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT IS THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT DESIGNATING
LOCATION THAT THAT'S STILL UP
IN THE AIR BUT WITH THIS BILL
IS ABOUT IS. MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE CITY OF
IRVINE ELECTED REPRESENTATIVE
IRVINE WILL CHOOSE LOCATION AND
NOT CALVET THERE IS SOME
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT CALVET
MAY ACTUALLY CHOOSE THE SITE
WHAT CALVET IS GOING TO DO AND
IS DOING IS DOING A STUDY OF
TWO DIFFERENT SITES AND WILL
PROVIDE A REPORT. THAT WILL BE
USED BY THE CITY OF IRVINE TO.
MAKE ITS DECISION. AND SO
THAT'S SIMPLY WHAT THE BILL
DOES OF WITH ME TODAY TESTIFY
IS MICHELLE JOHNSON A RESIDENT
OF IRVINE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU SENATOR
UMBERG. WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO
ALL RIGHT GOVERNMENT GO RIGHT
AHEAD- CHARGE ABOUT IT AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHELLE JOHNSON A THIRTY FOUR
YEAR IRVINE RESIDENT MY FATHER
WITH THE UNITED STATES NAVY
CAPTAIN AND SERVED TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS ACTIVE DUTY AND MY MOTHER
WAS A TENANT IN THE
NEIGHBORING- COURT AND SERVED
EIGHT YEARS ACTIVE DUTY.
THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF IRVINE
AND BEYOND THERE IS A DEEP
SUPPORT FOR ITS STATE VETERANS
CEMETERY ON THE FORMER AND I'LL
TURN. IT WOULD BE A WONDERFUL
ADDITION TO OUR COMMUNITY
REFLECTING THE SIGNIFICANT
HISTORY AND IMPACT ON THE CITY
A FORMER AIR. STATION AND
SERVICE MEMBERS. ONE FAMILY IN
IT WOULD PROVIDED. PLATE TO THE
THEIR LOVED ONES AND FOR THE
GREATER COMMUNITY IT WOULD
BECOME A PLACE TO HONOR OUR
VETERAN HEROES THE DEEP
GRATITUDE. I'M VETERANS HAVE
SACRIFICED TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY
AND MANY HAVE PAID THE ULTIMATE
PRICE. A PEACEFUL RESTING PLACE
IN A STATE VETERANS CEMETERY IS
THE FINAL BENEFIT THAT EVERY
VETERAN HAS EARNED AN A BENEFIT
THAT THEY AND THEIR FAMILIES.
TO SIR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
JOHNSON. I WILL NOW OPEN IT UP
FOR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT- DO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIR ME INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT
ON TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES ALL THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST GIVE
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
MODERATOR PLEASE- RELEASED THE
LINE EFFORTS SUPPORT WITNESSES.
AND ARE THERE ANY HERE IN THE
SENATE I SEE NONE AND WE ROOF
OVER TO ROOM ONE ONE TWO. AND-
SEE NONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE WILL NOW GO VIA
THE TELEPHONE AND SEE WHAT WE
HAVE MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FORTY
THREE. IF SO WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BUT IT
IS IN GERMAN IF YOU DO WISH TO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
IS SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK PARDON ME I SPOKE TOO
SOON JUST A MOMENT PLACE. AND
PLEASE CALL THE WITNESS
INDIVIDUALLY.
WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE. FIFTEEN THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS NICK YOU KNOW I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF BALLARD WHICH IS
THE VETERANS ALLIANCE OF ORANGE
COUNTY WE FIRST WISH TO THANK
EVERYBODY ON THIS COMMITTEE OUR
FELLOW VETERANS- WE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE. AND
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE THAT ALL OF OUR
FELLOWVETERANS ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE CONTINUED THEIR
PUBLIC SERVICE AND THE ROLE HAS
ELECTED OFFICIAL OF CALIFORNIA
WE BY THE PARTICULAR THANK-
SENATOR UMBERG FOR YOU KNOW ALL
OF HIS- HARD WORK AND
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS ISSUE AND
ALSO EXTEND OUR TREMENDOUS
GRATITUDE AND APPRECIATION TO
THE CHAIR WHO HAS- LET THIS
WITH A VERY- COMMON DELIBERATE
HAND HAS BEEN OPEN. TO LISTEN
TO ALL SIDES- AND THANK THEIR
CROWD. TO- FORTY BILL. AND FOR
YOUR SEARCH FOR OUR WE NEED TO
GO INTO THE NEXT WINTER ACTION
THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FORYOUR TESTIMONY.
MODERATOR TO HAVE SOMEONE ELSE.
SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THE
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
OKAY LET'S CHECK ONE MORE TIME
ON SENATE BILL FORTY THREE IN
SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN HE SAID NO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE
THE NEW ZERO. BETTER CARE THERE
IS NO ONE OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR. HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
THE SUPPORTERS ARE THERE ANY
WITNESS HERE HERE IN THIS
SENATE CHAMBERS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. I SEE
NONE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE ONE TWO
THAT WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION ON SENATE BILL FORTY
THREE. I SEE NONE. THANK YOU
NOW WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
MODERATOR- WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
THAT MIGHT BE- ON THE PHONE.
THAT MIGHT WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR. PLEASE
TELL ME THAT YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO PRESS ONE AND THEN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR OPPOSITION
PARDON ME IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
MIN ZERO. RESEARCH ANALYSTS
SAID NO BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
ONCE AGAIN H. TRY AGAIN IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION ON
SENATE BILL FORTY THREE ONE
MORE TIME. BASINGER WAS THE
FINAL CALL FOR PEOPLE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU FOR- YOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT AND THOSE WHO MAY WISH
TO TALK IN OPPOSITION- YOU CAN
WRITE THE COMMITTEE. SO WITH
THAT SENATORS- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR MELENDEZ. IT
THANK YOU I HAVE A QUESTION-
FOR THE AUTHOR FINING. THROUGH
WHICH TAKE QUESTION SURE.
WHAT'S COMMITTEE HEARINGS I
HOPE YOU TAKE A QUESTION- SO.
THE IGEST OF YOUR BILL SAYS
THAT IT REQUIRES CALVET
CORPORATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ORANGE COUNTY FOR THE
ACQUISITION STUDY DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
EQUIPPING- FOR THIS CEMETERY.
AND THAT'S ALREADY EXISTING LAW
SO WHAT EXACTLY DOES THE BILL
DO. BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT THE
DIGESTIVE TELLS ME WHEN IT DOES
BUT YOU SAID SOMETHING A LITTLE
DIFFERENT IN YOUR OPENING SO I
JUST WONDER WHERE IN THE BILL.
IS THERE SOMETHING I'M NOT
SEEING SO I THINK IF YOU LOOK
AT- IF YOU HAVE A BILLING FIVE
PAGE TWO. IF YOU LOOK AT
SECTION ONE WHERE IT SAYS
FOURTEEN TEN. EIGHTY ONE THE
BOTTOM IT SAYS IN THE CITY OF
IRVINE ACCORDING TO THE CITY'S
ENACTED LAWS AND ORDINANCES.
MISSY THAT FORTUNE YES SO WHAT
THE CONTROVERSY HAS BEEN- RIGHT
I DON'T THINK IT'S A REAL
CONTROVERSY BUT THE CONTROVERSY
HAS BEEN AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
CALVET OR THE CITY OF IRVINEIS
GOING TO CHOOSE A LOCATION.
WITHIN THE CITY OF IRVINE- THIS
BILL MAKES IT CLEAR THAT IN THE
CITY OF IRVINE. THAT THE CITY
WILL CHOOSE LOCATION IN
ACCORDANCE WITH ITS ENACTED
LAWS AND ORDINANCES- WE'VE
WE'VE ASKED CALVET TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT CALVET IS NOT
GOING TO MAKE THAT CHOICE THAT
CITIES CAN MAKE THAT CHOICE
BUT- THERE'S BEEN SOME.
RELUCTANCE TO DO SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. OKAY BUT THE
BILL DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY SAY.
THE CITY ONLY WILL CHOOSE THE
LOCATION AND NOT COUNT THAT
WHICH I THINK IS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THE ISSUE IS RIGHT
THAT'S CORRECT WHAT IT SAYS IS-
THAT THE STATE OPERATED
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY WHICH SHALL BE LOCATED
IN THE CITY OF OUR WINE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE CITY'S
ENACTED LAWS AND ORDINANCES.
OKAY- OKAY IJUST I YOU KNOW I
AM FAMILIAR WITH THIS ISSUE-
AND I KNOW THAT THIS HAS BEEN
KIND OF THE PING PONG. THAT'S
BEEN TAKING PLACE IN ORANGE
COUNTY WITH RESPECT TO THIS
CEMETERY WHICH IS-
DISAPPOINTING TO SAY THE LEAST
BECAUSE- RIVERSIDE NATIONAL
SERVICE THE MAJORITY OF. THE
VETERANS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LOS ANGELES IS EVEN ACCEPTING-
PEOPLE NOW I QUIT UNDER VERY
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES. SO WE DO
NEED ANOTHER CEMETERY I JUST I
GUESS AT. I AM VERY CONFUSED AS
I'M SURE YOU MUST BE AS TO WHY
THE CITY AND CALVET AND
EVERYONE ELSE INVOLVED CAN'T
COME TO SOME SORT OF AGREEMENT
BECAUSE THIS IS TAKING. A VERY
LONG TIME AND I THINK YOU KNOW
WE ARE FOND OF THINKING ARE
VETERANS FOR SERVICE IN- I
THINK YOUR ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER
THAN WORDS THE BEST WAY TO
THINK THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE TO
PROVIDE A PLACE FOR THEM FOR
THEIR FINAL RESTING PLACE- SO I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
ALTHOUGH I I'LL BE HONEST WITH
YOU AND TELL YOU I JUST. IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT IT DOES
ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAN IT'S
ALREADY BEING DONE BUT IF IT
HELPS MOVE THE PROCESS ALONG
I'M HAPPY TO BE ON BOARD WITH
THAT- AND HOPEFULLY YOU CAN.
USE YOUR INFLUENCE TO CONVINCE
THEM THAT THEY SHOULD STOP
BICKERING ABOUT IT AND GET
SOMETHING DONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- THURMOND IS I AGREE WITH
YOU 1100% BOB ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IN. MOVING FORWARD
IS THAT- WE CAN'T MOVE FORWARD
AS A STATE. UNTIL THE CITY OF
IRVINE DESIGNATES A LOCATION-
THEY HAVE BEEN. DISCUSSING THIS
FOR A LONG TIME THERE BEEN
MULTIPLE EFFORTS TO MOVE THE
CEMETERY TO DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
AND IN ORDER TO ELIMINATE ANY
CONFUSION WHATSOEVER AS TO WHO.
MAKES THAT DECISION IS LOCATION
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
SAYS CITY OF IRVINE YOU MAKE
THAT DECISION RECENTLY THERE
WAS A MOTION ON CITY COUNCIL
AND I. DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
ADOPTED OR NOT BUT I KNOW THAT
THERE'S SEVERAL MEMBERS WHO
SUPPORTED THE MOTION. CALVET
BASICALLY THE CITY WOULD FOLLOW
CALVET SLEEP CALVET IS NOT
GOING TO DESIGNATE A LOCATION
CALVET IS GOING TO DO A STUDY.
AND PROVIDE INFORMATION FOR THE
DECISION TO BE MADE. WELL THANK
YOU FOR THAT- AND I THINK THE
VOTERS ALREADY SPOKE ABOUT THIS
ABOUT WHAT THEY WANTED TO BE
DONE SELL. ITEMS YES I THINK
THAT'S TRUE- I THINK THERE'S
ALREADY- ORDINANCES ENACTED
BUT- THIS IS TO. ELIMINATE ANY
ISSUE AS TO WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR CHOOSING A LOCATION OKAY
AND JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY DOES-
NO RELATION TO HOW I WOULD VOTE
ON THE BILL BUT- GIVE ANY IDEA
HOW MUCH MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT.
STUDYING HIS AND PROVIDING
REPORTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE UP
TO THIS POINT I DON'T KNOW UP
TO THIS POINT I DO KNOW THAT
THAT THERE WAS A STUDY THAT'S
BEING CONDUCTED RIGHT NOW THAT
I THINK THEE WAS SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS APPROPRIATE
FOR THAT STUDY YES YEAH. OKAY
SO IT SEEMS LIKE AN AWFUL LOT
OF MONEY SPENT WITH NOTHING TO
SHOW FOR IT SO I HOPE THAT
THEY- CAN PULL THIS OFF. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER. YOUR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER SENATORS WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IT'S NOT
A CENTER BURKE DID YOU LIKE
CLOTHES AND SENATE BILL FORTY
THREE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
THAT SENATOR MELENDEZ IS
CORRECT THIS IS TAKEN TOO LONG
AND WE WANT TO MOVE IT ALONG-
THE CEMETERY- WILL PROVIDE
SPACE FOR TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND IT'S A NOT JUST THE SPACE
BUT IT'S ALSO THE COST COST
EIGHT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
BURIAL AND HAVING THAT BENEFIT.
WHICH IS EARNED BY BLOOD AND
SACRIFICE I THINK IS
APPROPRIATE AND SO I WOULD URGE
YOU NOT VOTE. GOOD DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. TO MOVE THE BILL
SENATOR EGGMAN- THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND ONCE AGAIN- SENATORS
PLEASE SPEAK IN THE MICROPHONE
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ARCHULETA BY
WHICH A LOT OF HIGH GROWTH. I
GROW HI EGGMAN THANKS MAN HI
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE ROTH. ROTH HI NUMBER
NUMBER I SEVEN ZERO THIRTY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT- BILL IS
OUT. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO AND-
NEXT LET'S SEE WE HAVE. A
CENTER GROVE CENTER GROVE
YOU'RE READY TO PRESENT YOUR
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY EIGHT YES
SIR OKAY GOOD MORNING TO YOU
THEN YOU MAY PROCEED GOOD
MORNING MISTER TERRY MEMBERS I
AM TAKING IMPRISONING SB SIX
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH IS BEING
SPONSORED BY THE SAMPOERNA DINO
COUNTY SASSER RECORDER CLERK
MISTER BOB DENTON A FORMER
SENATOR. THIS MEASURE
AUTHORIZES COUNTY ASSESSOR'S TO
OFFER PARTIAL PROPERTY TAX
DEDUCTIONS TO DISABLED VETERANS
PROPORTIONATE TO THEIR
PERCENTAGE OF DISABILITY RATING
PROVIDED BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
OR THE V. EIGHT. OR THE
MILITARY SERVICE FROM WHICH THE
VETERAN WAS DISCHARGED. OTHER
STATES OFFER PROPERTY TAX
CREDITS VEREEN IN VARYING
DEGREES AND- MANY ALLOW
VETERANS TO QUALIFY WITH
DISABILITY RATINGS LESS THAN
1100% INCLUDING FLORIDA
ILLINOIS AND TEXAS. CURRENTLY
I'M DISABLED VETERANS MAY
REQUEST A REDUCTION FOR THE
HOME'S ASSESSED VALUE ON THEIR
PROPERTY TAX FOR THE PURPOSES
OF DETERMINING THAT PROPERTY
TAX. ONLY IF THEY ARE 1100%
DISABLED BLIND IN BOTH EYES ARE
HAVE LOST TWO OR MORE LIMBS. IF
THE DECEASED VETERAN IS HAS A
SURVIVING SPOUSE THEY CAN ALSO
QUALIFY UNDER THOSE SAME
STANDARDS. HOWEVER WITHOUT THIS
BILL A VETERAN WITH A LIFE
CHANGING 50% DISABLED RATING
WOULD CONTINUE TO BE AN
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROPERTY TAX
DEDUCTION. ACCORDING TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN DATA.
THAT WAS PROVIDED BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND VETERANS WHO
HAVE SOME LEVEL OF DISABILITY
RATING AND IF THEY ON PROPERTY
WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR A
PROPERTY TAX DEDUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA. IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALONE THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
VETERANS WHO WOULD BE
INELIGIBLE AND OUR CURRENT LAW.
AT THE SAME TIME IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THE V. A.
ESTIMATED THAT CALIFORNIA. IN
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND HOMELESS VETERANS
WHICH- WAS FIVE TIMES MORE THAN
THE HIGHEST NEXT STATE US. SB
SIX FIFTY EIGHT WOULD BE THE
COULD BE THE ONE SAVING GRACE
FOR VETERAN IN HELPING THEM
KEEPING THEIR HOME AND GETTING
THEM THROUGH THE HARDSHIP UNTIL
THEY CAN GET BACK ON THEIR FEET-
WE ALL ARE WE'RE A WELL WE'RE
AWARE OF THE SACRIFICES THAT
OUR VETERANS MAKE. WHEN THEY
SWEAR TO DEFEND THIS COUNTRY
EVERYONE OF US ON THIS FLOOR
HAS MADE THAT SEEM. BOTH TO
THIS COUNTRY. WHAT WE MUST DO
AND WHAT WE MUST ALSO REMEMBER
IS THAT MANY VETERANS STRUGGLE
TO ADJUST BACK TO CIVILIAN LIFE.
THIS TRANSITION CAN BE EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THOSE
INJURED WHILE SERVING- SERVING
OR THOSE THAT STRUGGLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS SUCH AS PTSD.
THERE IS NO AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL
BENEFIT THE CAN EQUAL THE
AMOUNT OF LOSS ARE DISABLED
VETERANS FACE SB SIX FIFTY
EIGHT CAN PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF TO STRUGGLING VETERANS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. SB SIX
FIFTY EIGHT PASS OUT OF SENATE
COMMITTEE ON FINANCE A
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WITH THE
FIVE ZERO BIPARTISAN VOTE- WE
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES YET IN A
FORMER STATE SENATOR BOB DENTON
HE'S THE ASSESSOR RECORDER
COUNTY CLERK FOR SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY BROUGHT THIS ISSUE TO
ME. IS THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
IN THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT AND HE'LL BE TESTIFYING
BE VIA TELEPHONE SIR. MISTER
BURTON ARE YOU ON THE LINE
READY TO DEFY. YES I AM MISTER
CHAIRMAN PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD.
OKAY WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF S. B. AS SIX
FIFTY EIGHT- IS- CENTER GROVE
IT INDICATED THAT I'M CURRENTLY
THE SAMBAR DINO COUNTY ASSESSOR
RECORDER. WELL LET THE
LEGISLATURE- IN ASSUME THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES A COUPLE YEARS
LATER I PARTICIPATE A LOT IN
THE VETERAN RESOURCE FAIRS
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTY. AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY KNEW WHAT
WE HAD AVAILABLE UNFORTUNATELY
WE JUST DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH
AVAILABLE AND IT WAS REALLY- IT
WAS REALLY DISHEARTENING TO ME
THAT- HAVE SOMEBODY WHO WAS A
90% DISABILITY. AND I HAD TO
TELL THERE'S REALLY AND NOTHING
I HAVE FOR YOU OTHER THAN A
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLAR EXEMPTION
WHICH THEY TOOK THE SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR HOMEOWNERS
EXEMPTION. THEY WOULD BE
ENTITLED TO THAT EITHER. SO IT
JUST FELT TO ME LIKE IN
FAIRNESS. WE ARE LOOK AT DOING
SOMETHING AND SO. I DID TALK
TO- THE SENATE GROW ABOUT-
KERRY IN THIS BILL- THIS WOULD
EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY OF
DISABLED VETERANS. EXEMPTION BY
ALLOWING THE COUNTY ASSESSOR TO
APPLY A PARTIAL. DISABILITY
VETERANS EXEMPTION EQUAL TO THE
PERCENTAGE OF DISABILITY THE
VETERAN IS RATED. ABOUT THAT
READING IS DETERMINED BY THE
VETERANS ADMINISTRATION. AND
THE MILITARY AND THEN THEY'LL
GIVE US THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
AND CURRENTLY HAS A SAID THE
DISABLED VETERANS EXAM
EXEMPTION IS ONLY AVAILABLE. TO
SOMEBODY WHO IS A 100% DISABLED.
AND SO IT'S REALLY I THINK IN A
FAIRNESS ISSUE NOW HERE IN
SEMINOLE COUNTY WE HAVE ROUGHLY
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND VETERANS
NOT ALL OF THEM ARE HOMEOWNERS-
BUT THE ONLY FOUR THOUSAND OF
THOSE VETERANS HAVE A 100%
DISABILITY RATING. WHICH IS
ONLY ROUGHLY ABOUT 16% OF OUR
VETERANS. THIS IS A DIFFERENT
WORLD TODAY FOUR PEOPLE IN THE
MILITARY AND IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD. THAT WAS WHEN I SIR- I
SERVED DURING THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES DURING THE TIME WE
STILL HAD A DRAFT THAT WE WERE
FEEDING OUT TO AN ALL VOLUNTEER
SERVICE TODAY'S. NATIONAL GUARD
PERSONNEL. THEY ARE OUT OUT
THERE DOING THAT ONLY WORK FOR
US TO HELP US WITH NATURAL
DISASTERS AND THINGS LIKE THIS
BUT SOMETIMES THEY ARE ASKED TO
BE CALLED INTO DUTY- THE DEFEND
THIS COUNTRY AND BE OF SERVICE
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TWO. IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT IN
FAIRNESS CALIFORNIA IN THE
GREAT STATE IT IS IT IS IT IS.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
FOR SOMEBODY WHO HAS LIKE
EIGHTY OR 90% DISABILITY-
BECAUSE IT ISN'T JUST IT IT
JUST ISN'T THAT MUCH MONEY IN
THE TOTAL SCOPE OF THINGS BUT
IT IS A LOT OF MONEY. SOMETIMES
TO THESE TO THESE VETERANS
ESPECIALLY THE DISABLED VETERAN
COMMUNITY. SO I JUST LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
ORDER THANK SENATOR GROWTH. OF
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. FOR HEARING THIS-
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO. THANK
YOU MISTER FOR YOUR- AND NOW
WILL CONTINUE ON WITH THE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT- ANYONE
ELSE I'M GOING TO ALLOW THREE
MINUTES. IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
WILL DO THE SAME WITH
OPPOSITION- ANYONE TO- WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY AT THIS POINT
PLEASE. STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. AND NOW WILL MOVE
ON TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. I SEE NONE. AND ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
ONE TWO IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY EIGHT. I SEE
NONE. SO THANK YOU WITNESSES
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND TESTIFY. THOSE WHO WISH TO
VIA TELEPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT- ANYONE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY EIGHT. WE CAN
BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
NEW ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL PEOPLE OF SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS
BILL. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTEEN OKAY AND- PLEASE-
EACH WITNESS INDIVIDUALLY.
MODERATOR GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
SIX FIFTY EIGHT. ONE IN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING CARE
MEMBERS THIS IS SET THREE WITH
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDER
VETERANS COUNIL. OPPOSITE A
CISION AMERICA CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL CHAPTERS IN VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL ON SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT ONE
MODERATOR. A LINE TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING-
CHAIRMAN ARCHULETA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN LIVE QUEST KERN COUNTY
ASSESSOR RECORDER AND I'M
PLEASED TO JOIN- ASSESSING SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY ASSESSOR
RECORDER BOB DUTTON AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS
ASSOCIATION IN THEIR SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FIFTY EIGHT. THANK ONE
RECURRING FRUSTRATION WHICH
ASSESSORS ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THIS TURNING AWAY APPLICANTS
FOR DISABLED VETERANS EXEMPTION
BECAUSE THE VETERAN THOUGH
POSSIBLY EXPERIENCE CHALLENGES
ARE DIVERSITY. DUE TO A SERVICE
RELATED INJURY DOESN'T QUALIFY
WITHOUT A DISABILITY RATING OF
A 100% AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT ONE MARGARITA.
LINE. SIXTEEN JUSTIN BOND WITH
OUR HEROES DREAMS- AFTER
RETURNING HOME WAS IN A LAKE IN
THE WAR I REALIZE OUR BIGGEST
BATTLE COULD WE SEE STOOD HERE
ON THE HOME FRONT AND WE
STARTED A NONPROFIT WORKING
WITH SEVERAL OTHERS AND I SAW
THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE WORKERS
ARE FACING THAT SIR LET ME
INTERRUPT YOU FOR JUST A SECOND
JUST TO REMIND YOU WERE LOOKING
FOR YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION
AND- EITHER YOUR SUPPORT. ON
THE BILL PLEASE STATE. YES SIR
JUSTIN BOND- WHERE IS OUR
HEROES DREAMS AND A WEEK I AM
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
MODERATOR. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE THE SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK ONE MORE TIME ON SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY EIGHT. I WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF THE FINAL CALL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. SURE THERE
IS NO ONE VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
THE SUPPORTERS HERE WILL NOW GO
AHEAD AND GO ON TO THE
OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WISHING TO SUPPORT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. I SEE
NONE. AND IN ROOM ONE ONE TWO
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY EIGHT. I
SEE NONE. AND THANK YOU
WITNESSES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
MODERATOR- WE WILL GO ON. AND
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION MODERATOR.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. MODERATOR YOU PLEASE ASK
ONE MORE TIME. BUT INTEL IN
THIS IS THE FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE. THANK
YOU MODERATOR AND THANK THOSE
WHO CALLED IN SUPPORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN YOU CAN WRITE IN TO THE
COMMITTEE WITH YOUR COMMENTS
SENATOR DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I SHE
NINE. THEN CENTER GROVE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO RAISE OUR
RIGHT HAND PICKED IN OUR HAND
IN THERE AND SWEAR TO DEFEND
THIS COUNTRY AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC
AND- SOME OF US ARE NOT AS
LUCKY TO COME BACK- WITHOUT
SOME TYPE OF- DISABILITY OR-
DAMAGE. JUSTIN WAS ON THE PHONE
AND HE SHARED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE LEG THAT HE LOST
UNDER CURRENT LAW. HE CANNOT
AND IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS AND- BECAUSE THE
DISABILITY RATING THAT HE HAS
IS LESS THAN ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
A PERSON LIKE JUST IN ANOTHER
VETERANS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
WITH DISABILITIES LESSON 1100%
TO BE ABLE TO- GET A PROPERTY
TAX RETURN DEDUCTION- AND-
BASED ON THE VA DISABILITY
BENEFITS THAT ARE PROPORTIONATE
TO THE BENEFIT AMOUNT AND SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY AUSTIN. FOR
AN AYE VOTE SO THAT WE CAN
HONOR OUR VETERANS. THANK YOU
CENTER GROVE- THE MOTION IS-
THE FLOOR NOW OPEN PROMOTION.
SENATORS MOTION SENATOR
MELENDEZ THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN- PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE SO WE CAN HEAR YOUR
VOTE AND- CONSULTANT PLEASE
READ. THE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ARCHULETA BY WHICH LETTER I
WROTE I WROTE HI EGGMAN RIGHT
EGGMAN HI MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ
HI HUMAN. ROTH HI NUMBER NINE
NUMBER. SIX ZERO BUT ONE OF
THEM CALL WE HAVE SEVEN. THANK
THANK- WE HAVE SIX ZERO WILL
GOING TO HOLD IT ON CALL FOR
SENATOR NEWMAN AND- CHAU. YEP
THANK YOU ALL. WE'LL ASK
SENATOR NEWMAN TO COME BACK IN
WILL CLOSE IT UP AND IT'S IKE
TO THANK THE STAFF- FOR THE-
PUTTING US TOGETHER HERE TO
HEARING AND EVERYONE WHO
SUBMITTED THEIR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION TO MAKE COMMENTS IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS OR
THROUGH OUR WEBSITE- YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT. TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
OFFICIAL RECORDS THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF
THE GENDER IS STILL OPEN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU WE
WILL ADJOURN. WE WILL ADJOURN
AS SOON AS WE GET TESTIMONY
FROM. SENATOR JOSH NEWMAN WILL
HOLD THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON
A SHORT RECESS WE RETURN WITHIN
FIVE TO SEVEN MINUTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LAYS GERMAN WILL
RESUME THE MEETING AND WE WILL
LIFT THE CALL. AND- WILL CALL
FOR THE VOTE. SB SIX FIVE EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS FOR
FIRST RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY SIX ZERO. NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT HUMAN HIGH. THANK YOU
SENATOR WITH THAT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WE WILL. I'M SORRY.
THE BILL PASS SEVEN ZERO THREE
THREE AND- WITH THAT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND CONCLUDE THE MEETING
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
FOR PARTICIPATING.